carpe diem sees the mother freaking day
in February the hear the numbers 40
Trump 38 DeSantis now it's 52-21 he
tells this random 2012 NBA playoff story
as a metaphor the Indiana Pacers were
this close to dethroning to the Miami
Heat and LeBron James what has happened
since then since this stupid decision
that the coach made Indiana Pacers have
barely even made it the playoffs that
team has been dismantled Danny Granger
Paul George Roy Edward is out of the
league meanwhile LeBron James AKA Trump
in this story has won four NBA
championships since then he's still the
face of the league meanwhile the other
players are out of the freaking League
he also brought up Scott Walker Jeb Bush
these people are in the in the Dustbin
of history and that could potentially
happen to DeSantis